je mesure parfaitement l'inquiétude des
entreprises et des collectivités face à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie de
nombreuses communes malgré des efforts
de sobriété importants se demandent si
elles pourront payer leur facture et
maintenir ouvert tous leurs services
publics dans les prochains mois
chez le président Patriat c'est commune
ses élus vous les connaissez bien et les
membres de mon gouvernement et moi-même
avons échangé avec de nombreux élus
locaux et avec les représentants de
leurs associations
tous porte le même message et mon
gouvernement le porte avec eux cette
situation n'est pas tenable nous devons
agir et nous agissons alors nous
agissons d'abord à la racine pour faire
baisser les prix
les prix ne retrouveront pas les niveaux
artificiellement bas de la crise covid
mais ils ne peuvent pas non plus rester
à des niveaux artificiellement haut
tirés par la spéculation nous devons
ramener les prix de l'électricité à des
niveaux cohérents avec les coûts de
production et pour cela nous agissons
d'abord au plan européen nous y
travaillons et nous avançons bien vous
l'avez mentionné la Commission
européenne a ouvert la porte lors du
conseil de l'énergie vendredi dernier à
l'élargissement du dispositif qui a
permis de diviser le prix de
l'électricité par 3 en Espagne le
président de la République s'est
entretenu cette semaine avec le
chancelier allemand et avec la
présidente de la commission et on
soulève
a annoncé ce matin que la Commission
ferait des propositions pour le
plafonnement du prix du gaz lors du
Conseil européen ce vendredi et je le
précise nous travaillons en parallèle au
niveau français à d'autres mécanismes
pour ramener les prix à des niveaux
raisonnables mais nous agissons aussi
pour protéger les consommateurs le
bouclier tarifaire dont j'ai annoncé
mi-septembre la prolongation en 2023 et
la mesure la plus protectrice d'Europe
la hausse de la facture de l'énergie
pour les ménages mais aussi pour les
très petites entreprises et pour les
petites communes sera limitée à 15%.
ensuite je prends un engagement devant
vous aucune collectivité ni aucune
entreprise ne sera laissée dans une
impasse je pense en particulier aux
collectivités les plus exposées comme
celle qui connaissent des activités
saisonnières ou qui gèrent de grosses
équipements les ministres de l'économie
et de l'énergie ont réuni ce matin les
fournisseurs d'énergie les engagements
privés vont permettre qu'il n'y ait plus
d'entreprises ou de collectivités sans
fournisseurs d'énergie des offres seront
faites à chacun et la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie va publier des
indicateurs de prix pour que chacun
puisse vérifier que les ne sont pas
abusives par ailleurs s'agissant des
entreprises nous allons améliorer les
aides exceptionnelles pour les gros
consommateurs d'énergie s'agissant des
collectivités elle bénéficient d'ores et
déjà d'acompte pour soutenir leur
trésorerie et le fait filer de sécurité
mis en place pour traiter les cas les
plus difficiles sera renforcée le
gouvernement présentera prochainement
des propositions donc vous voyez
monsieur le Président Patriat nous
protégeons nos compatriotes nous
protégeons nos collectivités nous
protégeons nos entreprises et nous
veillerons à ne laisser personne sans
solution je vous remercie
[Musique]